it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes
Oh what in the world welcome to movie
fights hashtag movie fights live we got
a good one for you today and I gotta say
hello to hashtag gal nation who percival
is not in the house but I am wearing an
owl pin so there you go
Oprah in my car please don't report me
concern for personal life to jump at the
show okay I'll tweet out her some how
he's doing after the show um first up
you know from Collider heroes and he is
he changed the game speed round wise
fastest mountain the west poisoned row
so excited for health fights I'm so like
the tweet is there an didn't spoil
anything oh this is the theme that I
didn't know I needed in my life yes
no one knew they needed this Hellboy
theme to their movie fight second he's a
movie fights veteran host of podcasts
the ride hi Mike Carlson hi hell thanks
for having me oh and I'm always excited
to see what t-shirt you're wearing
that's a pretty sweet hell okay well
it's Hello Kitty new Japan professional
wrestling they've teamed up thank you
everyone if they would give me a round
of applause so sweet
yeah so this I got this a long beach at
the new Japan show a great show great
kitty thank you for that cool story that
is an awesome shirt Mike Carlson thank
you for being here
and you normally see her in the social
media chair but she is fighting today I
wonder how much cursing she's going to
do Danielle Radford today I'm just in it
for me I'm no longer in it for the
people I'm just kidding I love either
people right on um Danielle thank you
for yeah coming to fight I have to look
I know the rules now and I can't get us
demonetized cuz I work here
the cursing will be at like a nun right
it's a nun cursing radford it's a new
day okay and you know what that could be
a drinking game for you know if you see
Daniel curse throwing back and I see if
y'all see me curse someone will throw
something at me and judging the fights
will be myself and we haven't come up
with a nickname for them Ron long and
Ryan
wrong online oh yeah I am
Ron Lionel oh yeah yeah there we go ah
lon Harris hoot hoot
how you doing long hoot hoot to you as
well good to see you brother
thank you for holding it down it always
my pleasure in the fact zone and no tool
Ryan so would you please I'll let them
know how your capacity works yes hello
good question so I will be Danielle's
place as the voice of the people sorry
people
there's poles on Twitter there's poles
on YouTube but the only one we're
counting for the game today is on
YouTube it's not one that's in the iCard
in the top right hand corner to look at
the screen should be right above here
that'll come up after each question has
been setting the answers are out there
if you don't know how to bring up the
poles there's instructions in the
description there's people whose names
are blue in the chat they can help you
I'll do my best to help as well but if
you when in doubt if you're just refresh
and you should be fine
excellent Ryan thank you for holding it
down over there and again we are going
to have three regular round questions
the top two scores after those three
questions we'll move on to the speed
round it's anybody's game in the
speedrun you'll be down three Oh make a
furious comeback and to take it for
three first person to four points wins
okay what I wanna do a little movie
fighting you guys I guess so yeah JT
please drop that sick-ass package
[Music]
thanks door okay so question one alright
so the question says in honor of the new
Hellboy I don't know if we need to honor
Hellboy sacrifice for ya I don't know if
the reviews are have earned honor but
yes because Hellboy is dropping this
weekend we asked who should play Satan
in a movie what actor should play Satan
in a movie and we're gonna start with
coin so I went with an actor that is
just crying out for a leading role in a
film an actor that is so overdue for a
feature about him and this is a
character that deserts its own movie a
character with mythology a character
that can last through the decades nay
millennia and an actor with the gravitas
to pull off all the depth of a fallen
angel and that is of cursed course
sterling ke Brown sterling K Brown is so
slept on I want this guy in every
franchise and he's starting to be I want
this guy leading them though I don't
want him as a supporting player I loved
him as into Joe boo but I wanted to see
that movie more than I necessarily
wanted to see other things in the Black
Panther I wanted to see his story I want
to see his story and this is us whenever
there's a Randall centric episode I am
all-in now on this is us he shows his
impossible versatility and he steals
every scene and predator he showed that
in a movie that not many positives he
could be a positive and he was sleazy he
was fun he brought gravitas to a
character and a script that didn't
really work and an obviously in black
panther every time he was on screen that
was present in a movie with everyone
having presence it's so hard to stand
out in a movie with that much talent and
for me he did and finally in hotel
Artemus last year which I'm one of the
seventeen people that saw he showed that
he can be two-faced
he could be someone you didn't trust he
could be someone that brought a movie
through a strange through line and
that's exactly what Lucifer / satan
needs to be so sterling came Brown was
my only choice before the devil
sterling came by on thank you koi Mike
okay we've seen a lot of different
Devils in film and television and
literature we've seen you know cool
devil we've
very evil devil but we have never seen
old cranky man who lives in the
countryside devil which is why I'm
choosing Robert Duvall the great Bobby D
we all know him he's in as I think mid
to late 80s I'm looking for a devil
that's different than all the other
Devils this is a devil who lives in the
countryside in a little old shack who
offers homespun wisdom okay it is evil
homespun wisdom because he is the devil
but this is gonna be a totally new take
okay because let's be honest the devil
has seen a lot he's been around a long
time and he probably wouldn't be some
jacked-up devil who's always shootin
fire or some slick guy that cares he's
weathered he's tired he's tired of being
the devil he's tired of living in hell
which is also this Shack in the middle
of nowhere
okay Bobby D is gonna bring something
different to the role of the devil I
think this is gonna be um I guess I'll
name the movie it's just called The
Devil's ranch okay that would be what
the movies called he's gonna bring a
whole new dynamic to the character of
the devil Bobby D Robert Duvall that's
my pick
all right The Devil's ranch and that's a
that's a ranch people live on a dressing
there is dressing in on the ranch but
you could call it all the devil's ranch
is what I'm saying
Thank You Danielle what do you got um so
for me I picked someone who is not only
convinced us of their power has not only
convinced us of their ability to seduce
but as always also convinced us of their
ability to wear a tight suit and some
horns I am going with Kate Blanchet Kate
Blanchet on numerous occasions has not
only shown us that she has the acting
chops and the ability she has not only
shown us that she can seduce anyone from
anywhere with her ability she has also
shown us that she can turn on a dime and
one moment she can be reeling you in by
being the sweetest kindest most
wonderful person you've ever seen and
then a me
go come incredibly powerful I will
destroy you and everything you love if
you do not do what I do she again she is
powerful she's seductive
she's a planchette and that's why I
think she'd be a great devil three real
good choices find it out guys these both
of these choices they're both hot okay
they're both like youngish and hot what
about weathered and soot-covered that's
what the devil should be all right
we've seen these cool slick people doing
it before let's get someone who has a
hound dog at his feet why would the
devil be like I live for eternity I am
weathered and tired like I so understand
might be like I feel like my bones
should hurt and also such a huge part of
the mythology of the devil if we were
going with traditionally the devil is
that the devil was the most prized
beautiful angel in the world
so why would the devil stop being the
most charming gorgeous wonderful person
in the world and decide who's gonna be
cranky in a shack because everyone gets
tired of being on top let's be honest
it's always it made me if the devil is
trying to win an Oscar of any uglies
himself up and lives in that Shack so we
can win the Oscar this is an
oscar-winning temple this is this is the
devil devil and that's unfortunately
Larry the society in which we live in in
which you know hotness rules the day and
the last time we did a comedy devil it
was Little Nicky and bedazzled neither
of which worked out well so I think who
said anything about comedy devil Robert
Duvall as the devil you described a
comedy no I did not no there's nothing
funny about my movie at all this is a
sad drama yes he's gonna see you about
tell you about the horrors that he's
seen all right he's gonna get a fishing
line and ya wanna watch a movie about
the devil being sad the devil was the
bad guy shouldn't we want the devil to
be sad that's like what you can movi
about Thanos being sad yeah dude you
should be sad you did bad things
no he was sad in the movie at the end my
thing with Kate Blanchet is she has an
inherently cold frigid nest and she's
evil and I think the devil is hot and
warm I don't see that coldness
translating and she's already kind of
played the devil and Narnia didn't work
out so well for her and and I love when
she has a warm Thunder currently and I'm
not there when she was playing Bob Dylan
there's a certain charm to her when she
lets herself be on and I feel
the way she'd played the devil would be
cold and menacing in a way that wouldn't
work where sterling I think that she is
once man I think that she is K
planchette and I think she's going to
know exactly at which moment to turn on
the charm and be warm be like Carol be
someone who can bring you in and make
you want to be with her and then when
you know it's not going to work or when
she knows that her machinations are not
gonna work she's gonna be someone who's
going to bring it down and I do love
sterling Clank k Brown I think he is a
fantastic actor however you did mention
that you want someone who was a falling
angel you want someone you've already
said he can be sleazy he has that
presence he can do all of these things
we haven't I have not seen enough of him
to see him truly be at the end of the
day the devil is the devil and when he
make the devil mad the devil is gonna
show his power I haven't seen that level
of power from streaming K Brown I would
love to we haven't seen it yet and he
hasn't shown that he can actually do
that season 2 episode 3 this is us
full-blown meltdown into rage and then
when he's upset at his family like it
his kids and he's having a full mental
breakdown for me that's what the devil
would experience he's going through a
lack of self a lack of consciousness a
lack of belief in himself but then he
also has to be the devil and support
himself so to me being the devil is kind
of like being a parent that doesn't know
if they can handle their [ __ ] so to me
that sterling came around has proven
himself for three seasons well isn't the
parent the devil is the devil is a rebel
the devil is the one who was parented
too hard and is fighting back against
being parented so on yeah that's
sympathetic okay I want to feel bad for
the devil all right that's what I'm
interested in of course why wouldn't you
feel bad for grandpa W offer you a cider
a hot cider because it's hell we don't
have to Logan everything and it sounds
like a tumbleweed movie that's a seven
dollar Walmart bid like he's done a
bunch of those lately none of them have
been seen it's not been working for
directing this movie it'll be good
seeing the horrors of the devil he
causes the horrors he is the horror so
for him it wouldn't be a man I've seen
so much bad stuff gone down you did the
bad stuff at something you might dude
you ain't got no one to blame but
yourself I don't feel bad for somebody
who created their own badness and now
has to live in a weird Shack but look at
his upbringing I also worry that Cate
Blanchet we've seen her takes on the
devil before we've seen like I said
Narnia we've seen her in four we've seen
these movies where she's played that
role we've never seen this that a
sterling came around I think it's a
really good opportunity for an actor to
get his time to shine versus someone
that's played very similar roles and
done well but we've seen it well
speaking of very similar roles and one
thing that you don't talk about very
much is the Lord of the Rings where is
that is an opportunity to watch someone
who was engaging and who you feel like
is someone who's going to help people
who was able to turn on a dime I think
that your argument only helps me because
you're showing that she is able to play
all of these different characters or was
stirring Kate Brown he tends to have
more nuanced performances where he's
doing a lot with the eyes he's doing a
lot with the lip quiver and all of those
are wonderful and I appreciate them but
sometimes the devil got a devil but
hearts Hotel aren't met the devil Devils
like she's a big brother taking care of
his little brother awesomely played by
Brian Tyree Henry and you see his rage
you see its passive pathos you see how
much conviction he has and I think that
we need that take on the devil more than
we've seen something we've had a hundred
times before Robert Duvall sorry Robert
Duvall has this rage - it's not gonna
all just be sunshine and evil lemonade
okay he has anger have you seen the
Great Santini this is something he
hasn't tapped into lately but it exists
he's a long storied film career he has
the anger he can summon it again in his
late 80s okay I believe it you can get
multi dimensions here you feel bad from
one minute then he stopped then you go
oh yeah maybe he's the worst person I've
ever seen there's gonna be layers to
this it's not OneNote all right let's uh
shift gears into final thoughts coy take
us there
so with this is us we're able to see an
actor portray every type of motion
through decades through many different
life experiences his brother endangers
his child and you see rage behind his
eyes in a way that is palpable and
incredible then through predator and
this is us - enough is Estelle earnest -
movies that weren't that good he was the
shining light of positive and he is a
powerhouse actor that is able to bring
source material that might not be so
great up level so if you
great team behind this movie he can make
it even better and the actor himself
deserves to show the rain she showed in
all these smaller parts he needs his
time to shine and there's no better
person for the devil himself needs to be
both angelic and menacing and certainly
Kay Brown is that thank you Mike these
other two choices are the safe choice
they're boring they're slick they're
cool we all know oh that's what the
devil looks like it's basically like you
could plug him into bedazzled with a low
with Elizabeth Hurley spar as the devil
like we got it we've seen that before
this is a totally new take but this is
also an actor that can do anything you
want he doesn't have to do these kindly
old grandpa he's done that for a long
time but in addition to just being a
kindly old grandpa he has the rage he
has the range we can actually get in
there and do a character's character
study which is something that is a grand
tradition in entertainment taking the
most evil character and getting inside
their head seeing what makes them tick
and then maybe even feeling a little
sympathy before then flipping again and
feeling ultimate disdain for them Robert
Duvall is gonna bring a fresh new take
on the classic character the devil
thanks Mike Carlson Daniel Radford and
once again I you know I I think that
Robert Duvall is a very captivating
character you're telling me you want to
go in a character study and for me I do
not feel like you have sold what a
character study with him would really be
I feel like you're just pivoting to
let's do old man devil and I feel like
that isn't something that is necessarily
going to be as interesting as we all
would love it to be with Sherman Kate
Brown I agree with you that he does need
to be in a role which shows off all of
his range and everything that he can do
he has not done enough yet to prove to
me that he would be a convincing devil
unlike a Cate Blanchet who was a long
story career we have seen her beat every
kind of person you would want to be we
have seen her be regal we have seen her
be humble we have seen her be seductive
we have seen her we'd be warm we have
seen her be cold we have seen her look
hot we have seen all of the things that
we would need to see for a devil that I
would want to see who was both capable
of extreme charming and vulnerability at
the same time can turn on that power at
a moment's notice
time there it is okay three strong
arguments LAN what's going
in the fact zone we have we have two
facts the first one there was mention of
Robert Duvall's age he's 88 years old
just want to put that out there
everybody my god it suddenly coin
chatrooms not super happy with you that
was not Cate Blanchett as the White
Witch in the Narnia films
that's Tilda Swinton my friend I did not
mention that they've been so I don't
slow down anymore all right
so some great arguments here yeah lots
of good stuff Mike I really loved your
take initially because you like you laid
out a specific vision I love like that
you know the cabin in the middle of
nowhere and everything but I think they
started to ding you a little bit on just
you know the the tone of the film and
then you said you were directing it I
don't know if that like I'm not sure of
your acumen as someone to helm a major
motion picture eyes and but I feel like
they dinged you a little bit on where
that would go it came down to Danielle
and and coy for me and coy yeah Danielle
I thought hit you with sterling K Browne
has not shown this yet but then you came
back and you had a couple of receipts
who is concluding sts-2 III of this is
us and you hit back with Danielle I got
a take away obviously the Narnia thing
but she was still hella was very similar
so just by a hair I got a go koi long I
thought all three of these arguments
were very compelling I really like
Mike's Robert Duvall pitch
for most of this round out to say but
then I thought at the very end I really
thought Danielle had a very strong final
argument and sort of tied everything
together and and you know like the fact
that she's already played a character
that's sort of devilish it away like I
think if anything the kind of
disappointed favor we know that she's up
to it and could do it so I'm gonna go
with Danielle okay one for one for
Danielle Ryan does the internet that
does the internet help us out here I
think they do I'm refreshing right one
last sec to make sure boom so yes with
52% of the vote Cate Blanchett is the
winner twenty four percent for Robert
Duvall twenty two percent for Sterling a
brown all right where is it is really
good fantastic more all right Danielle
takes a one to nil to nil lead Mike and
coy looking to get on the board here is
question number two in this hellish
movie fights keeping with the theme of
Hellboy we asked what's the best movie
featuring the devil in any role man the
Church of Satan is gonna love this
episode finally my beliefs get to work
oh you're an Anton LaVey
believe in an actual devil and as much
as they believe that like a human it
okay fine all right so we asked the best
movie featuring the devil in any role
and were gonna start with player number
two Mike South Park bigger Longer &
uncut folks one of the best movie
musicals of all time this is like we
will remember so many different things
all these songs are great it's something
if you go back it like is bursting with
life this is the thing I think actually
that is kind of responsible for giving
the show the longevity that it had
because I think I'll up it to this point
like people like South Park but maybe
the buzz was wearing off
I believe this movie kind of cemented
those guys and this franchise is like
the real deal and it's still going today
I think that there's so many memorable
parts of this there's so many fun
characters I think other characters were
even cemented in the movie I think this
thing does look like a better job than
the TV show I think it's very funny it's
very original and it just it works even
without just being like a shock shock
humor thing which is what I think people
thought South Park was it stands the
test of time as I said one of the best
movie musicals South Park thanks Mike
Danielle all right so I'm going with one
of my favorite movies which is the
devil's advocate you have al pacino as
one might say at the height of his
powers he has taken on as an attorney
then a young lawyer and a fantastic
Keanu Reeves and during that point he
does again exactly what you wouldn't
want the devil to do where he twists and
turns and makes people's minds play
tricks on them and going beyond just the
fact that it's a portrayal of the devil
that I really like the movie itself is
great it is a suspenseful horror movie
you don't know what's real and what's
fake
there are fantastic performances from Al
Pacino which you could expect out
Charlize Theron doing one of her first
big movies the effects are fantastic and
there is one of the most bombastic
amazing speeches at the end of this
movie along with some very very
incredibly intriguing twists and turns
and reveals and so I'm going with
devil's advocate thanks Danielle coy
mystics gallery
and we're gonna talk about a beautiful
movie about the occult a movie a bit
ahead of its time a movie that if it
came out even two years later I think
would have done a lot better a movie
based on a very tricky tricky graphic
novel series subject matter comic book
and that is of course Constantine
Constantine stars Keanu Reeves and it
was just this staggering foray into
darker comic-book lore it is a movie
about a different tricky power set to
translate as a movie with a lot of
mythology it is a movie that deals with
the devil and a very head-on way and it
is a movie that really lets you see
Keanu Reeves as action and drama start
the movie let's chenery's be equal parts
neo and dramatic actor to me it was neo
meets the devil's advocate it was seeing
actually letting Keanu Reeves play with
all of his sensibilities in one film and
at that point I don't think a lot of
people and and faith encounter needs to
do a lot and and this really revitalized
that for me cuz this was I think five
years after the matrix and we saw those
sequels and what they were but for me
this movie not only gave us a great
devil in Peter Stormare it gave us a
very visually iconic devil when you meet
the devil he's dressed in all white he
shatters this glass and you're walking
through it and that beautiful early we
don't know what CGI is gonna be yet so
we're shaping the play of it and I
really remember so many visuals from
this film I remember beats in this film
I remember like diamant Honsou leads the
occult in a way that you feel like
you're part of the world quickly and I
love when a movie tells you a mythology
that you've heard a hundred times but it
feels fresh and new and it also feels
real I felt like I could walk into the
world of Constantine constantly and that
is a great way to have a devil film
alright a really Keano centric round
let's find it out okay so I as you know
I'm a huge DC fan I love vertigo I love
all these things let's take out for a
second the fact that Constantine
neutered Constantine because we're not
talking about the comics I'm bringing it
up because I know people in the chat and
other people are gonna bring it up we're
not talking to a team we're not talking
about Constantine they're Hellblazer
the books we're talking about
Constantine the movie and even with that
prior knowledge of constant of
Hellblazer the books it still feels like
there is a more interesting version of
that character and of that movie out
there that they did not quite reach it
felt like there were parts that were
lacking and that they could have made
better you can feel it even if you don't
have any knowledge of how blazer the
comic you can feel that movie hitting
itself hitting its head against the wall
and against its rating so to me I had a
really almost the exact opposite
experience where this to me was a movie
showing that you can make a mainstream
version of a comic that wasn't
mainstream so I literally the opposite
where I was like oh this is a thing that
no one will ever understand but they
found a way to make it digestible it was
like when my grandma called me and said
who's phantos I was like you made
phantoms relatable to my grandma to me
Constantine was that it was a movie
about John Constantine an [ __ ]
Shane smoking kind of hard to tolerate
person but you cast the most likeable
guy in the world can terrines and then
you kind of oh yeah maurices darling but
you look amazing I would argue that he's
not the most likable person I am the
most likable person in the world Tom
Hanks are the two guys left and actually
be surprised by if something bad
happened around them like that the two
so to me I feel like this movie played
with all the best of Keanu and it played
with the mythology whereas I feel like
the devil's advocate
Al Pacino played Al Pacino in a very cut
and dry if the devil was involved in law
and then you were waiting for Al Pacino
scenes I don't remember any scenes
except for the speech and the whole
movies remember the iconic dressing room
scene where Charlize Theron is hanging
out with all of the other lawyer wives
and they slowly start becoming demons
and that is the beginning of her
breakdown where she starts completely
freaking out doing one of the best
performances of her entire career to
lose her to ultimately killing herself
I'm sorry you don't remember that
because that's an amazing I don't
remember but let's be honest we're
trying a conic scenes we all remember
ten scenes from the South Park movie
versus these two movies let's be honest
this is which also by the way I gotta
say this is a hard thing to do a comedy
musical there's like 15 good comedies in
the history of movies and this is one of
them like this is impossible to make
this and a TV show adaption also which
is insanely crazy those are always like
very bad so this is iconic scenes we can
list them the tough part for me is
always that it's a very piece of its
time which I appreciate but it's it's
very surfaced to me like it's it relates
to those things and I can't I never go
back and rewatch that personally I don't
really watch the show I don't watch the
movie it feels like a piece of time and
then they move on and I appreciate it it
at the time but it's not something that
stands as a movie to me it's a piece of
the time or a piece of the show well I
would disagree cuz I'm
this is actually when they first started
getting into stuff that would that had
themes this is about censorship it's
about free speech in addition to just
about friendship and such I think this
is actually starts these because the
early South Park was just sort of like
swearing and weird stuff and this is
when we start to get like interesting
themes stuff now that they've actually
in the show of comer gone back and said
they were wrong about so you kind of
have a whole arc of like people changing
and actually their ideas in there we
can't say it's an arc of people changing
because that doesn't happen in the movie
that's completely understand that we
can't bring Constantine a comic book
into this then we can't beliefs a park
the TV show what did that that's fair I
do feel like judging them for each of
their merits just the South Park movie
isn't the some of the South Park show so
it's not as fondly remembered for me and
also you have to have intimate knowledge
of the South Park show in order to get
South Park the movie where as devil's
advocate stands on its own you don't
need to have seen anything else you
don't need to have seen any of these
other movies you don't need to be a fan
of it in the same way that you said you
know Constantine was something that
you're you know suddenly you'll
strengthen your grandma understood who
Thanos was devil's advocate doesn't ask
anyone to know who anyone is except the
devil which we all know we're in with
South Park you know you cannot go into
that movie fresh you have to know the
tropes of that coffee show you have to
know the tropes of that it's still a
fantastic movie but it does not stand on
his own I think that's a very part of an
important part of movie me I have to
disagree my dad had seen one episode of
South Park he didn't like it he took me
to see the movie my first r-rated movie
in the theatre that's how sheltered I
was as a kid I'm very old now I took a
man as soon as uncle [ __ ] started he
loved it it was like the funniest thing
he'd ever seen he didn't know like
missus he didn't know the people for me
imagery is such an important part of the
movie especially if I put the occult in
Devils and to me the devil's advocate I
remember Al Pacino I remember Keanu
Reeves being in it but to me it's a very
lawyer based film that feels very I I
know I might be wrong here but it's very
courtroom drama based where's vehicle
with TM on Honsou Rachel Weisz Keanu
Reeves I remember so much imagery like
the water the glass the the cymbals and
chatter even doing this all the time was
always awesome all that times mythology
the devil himself
there is so much imagery you actually
have you get to see the lake of fire at
the end you get to see a portal open
where you get to see some parts of hell
you get to see again those women in that
dressing room slowly turn into the
devils that they actually are in the
demons that they are while they seduce
and corrupt his wife you get to see
what's happening in Charlie's Thrones
mine when parts of the house start
slowly transforming I'm guessing that
maybe you didn't get a chance to see
this before the show and I completely
understand because I don't know if it's
streaming go find it if it is but I
think that that's that's more of a case
of you not remembering it because you
haven't seen the movie because the
visuals in that do absolutely take you
right back into hell while also showing
you a world that is part of our world
and showing you what it would look like
if someone was able to affect someone in
the brain and show what would happen if
you were being seduced and if you were
being tricked by someone who wanted you
to do something for him he very much
wanted Charlize Theron scare to to kill
himself so that spoiler his son and his
daughter can remember prefer and so in
order to do that he drove her insane and
you get to watch her descent not only by
her actions but also in the way that
it's portrayed in the film I feel like
you and I have the same strengths we're
seeing in each four films and then it's
the world underneath ours that we feel
like are a part of it and all those
things so it's just a matter of genre
for me between like Oregon is very
similar yours courtroom mine action
comic based and all those style choices
but to me what holds mine up above that
is the devil himself in the party plays
for me
Al Pacino stayed out Pacino throughout
the film at no points and I feel like he
was the devil
I felt like Al Pacino was talking at
Keanu Reeves and telling the do bad
stuff for me Peter Stormare had this
dripping dark viscosity of evil that
really established the entire occult and
it like glued the movie together so to
me the devil being the glue versus the
devil being al pacino really separate
Gina this was out but you know being
sent of a woman Al Pacino while he is
talking to a very gentlemanly southern
lawyer and Keanu Reeves and while
teaching this very humble lawyer how to
become this wall street esque badass in
the courtroom bull and doing it in the
way that imagines scent of the sense of
a woman and those powers and him turning
them on his head and suddenly he becomes
you know from this good guy who's
showing someone to how to embrace their
confidence and their power suddenly he
becomes oh and also by the way I'm super
the devil I'm pregnant
mom and YouTube and your sister we don't
do this these are two movies I think
though that bother both like good
incompetent movies they lack some
personality they like a pop whereas like
South Park you know you can feel like
the who the people who made it are these
your final thoughts I will absolutely do
that hell thank you this is an alt like
a weird weirdo Comedy property that ends
up being nominated for an Oscar blame
Canada song by Robin Williams at the
Oscar like that is crazy that is how
much of an impact the movie made and how
everyone had to recognize how good it
was as a movie I think that if going
back and watching all three of these you
will come away remembering the most from
South Park versus another two competent
devil movies that's what I'm gonna say
thank you Mike Danielle so again for me
the the musicality and the humor of
South Park is great I still feel like as
far as a movie that stands on its own it
does not and again does these are movies
that are about whether or not whether or
not they are good devil movies not
necessarily about whether the devil is
good in them and so for me I think that
is also what takes away from Queens
argument because coy argues that Al
Pacino is not a good devil this is not
about whether or not the devil in this
is good this is about whether or not
this is a good movie featuring the devil
and for me between the performances the
the visual effects the slides in
character and being able to see how the
devil would actually affect these people
in the real world and corrupt their
souls and what that does to them and
their minds along with being great acted
and yeah it's a procedural who don't
love a procedural I'll tell you what
nobody who watches CBS everybody love a
procedural so that combined with all of
those things is why I believe the
devil's advocate is the better moving
Thank You Danielle coy so I heard both
your statements I think the movie that
needs pop should be the one the one that
you want to watch again the one you
revisit and I agree that it's it's all
about not the devil himself but the
devil the film involving the devil so
not specifically opportunist performance
but befall ty have with your film is
that Al Pacino's performance never felt
like the devil was in the movie so it's
not a fault of the performance as a
fault of the film never capturing for me
devil like the
never felt like I was watching a movie
about the devil or movie about hell I
felt like I was watching a movie about
actors playing the devil and Kennedys
playing opposite and actor playing
Neville to me the best movie is the
movie that fully immerses you in a world
of movie that fully puts you in a story
a movie that fully makes you believe
that world exists a movie that is the
best is the one that fully encapsulate
the entire story so to me this one the
Constantine adaptation is it supersedes
what it's adapting in a way that makes
it more digestible and mainstream I like
Hellblazer the comic but I like that
Constantine was able to make Hellblazer
without Hellblazer and it's a movie that
fully emergency in the world with all
performances where you're not thinking
of the actor playing them all
of the dialogue all the actions you're
fully immersed in the world and most of
all you fully believe in the occult by
the end of the film Rachel Weisz is
imagery Sears into my mind Peter
Stormare in that white suit seared in my
mind so there's images there's catchy
dialogue there's believable characters
and at no point was i watching an actor
play the devil I was watching a movie
about the devil with incredible
performances time there it is long let's
go to the fact zone not a lot of wrong
facts I should point out Mike is
definitely the most likable person in
the room because Mike discussed how the
movie sort of pivoted South Park the
movie only came out two years after
South Perth debuted on TV that's crazy
sapper tab you'd in 1997 the film came
out in 1999 I thought it was a much
bigger gap there Wow
lon please go ahead and give us your
thoughts on around this is really tough
I thought everybody made really great
arguments and and brought it back to the
movie like by the end we were really
discussing like which of the three
movies is the best it wasn't just about
that what you thought that was cool yeah
it's hard to say I think by the end it
sort of came down to koi versus Danielle
to me I thought Mike did a great job of
of arguing here's why this was like an
unexpected treat feature in the devil
but I didn't necessarily feel like you
were here's the best movie but
ultimately I thought koi had a really
great final argument wrapping it all up
so I'm gonna go with koi all right
that's one for koi yeah i man I gotta
say Mike I i completely agree with
mike's choice but as far as the
humans go I gotta take myself out of it
yeah I also would not I don't agree that
Constantine is the best of these three
movies right god I thought Danielle
leveled from devastating blows on koi
when she was talking about just how
disappointing Constantine was for a lot
of the fans and separate from that and I
just remember the the not having a
totally satisfied feeling with that film
and so came it really came down to Mike
and Danielle for me and yeah at the end
of the day even though I don't agree
that devil's advocate is better I
thought Danielle made the stronger
arguments as the film as a whole so yeah
I gotta go Danielle so it's one for
Danielle one for koi Ryan what do you
got on a roll all right so this is one
of the closest polls I've seen so I'm
only 15 votes literally the number is 15
votes made a difference of this one and
with 42% of the vote devil's advocate
got it what was it was so it was devil's
advocate and then devil's advocate at
42% South Park at 38% only 15 votes less
and then Constantine was at 18% Wow
crazy my goodness all right Danielle
taking a commanding 2o lead I love that
your dad loved forget it it's good stuff
all right so coy and Mike looking to get
on the board
here's question number three all right
continuing with the hell theme Greece is
getting a prequel nothing to do with
that healthy um let's talk about Greece
- okay so
oh sorry I know you're a big michelle
pfeiffer and Danny techno what's a yeah
he was the original Danny Zuko on
Broadway we go and put some respect on
that man's name yes oh thank heavens of
grease to hell
okay so grease is getting a prequel
called summer loving what movie musical
should get a prequel and what should it
be about and we'll start with Danielle
so for me one of the reasons why I think
people are railing so hard against this
summer loving prequel are many-fold for
one thing everything in the movie is
being described in the first song we
already know they met there was
splashing they fell in love tell me more
tell me more you already told me
everything I needed we're good
also there is the problem with prequels
which is something that we dealt with
was solo and the things of the problem
of being recast I picked a movie where
not only does it not really require
recasting it also expands the world and
makes you understand more about
motivations I pick Little Shop of
Horrors and from my pitch I want to take
us to the land of Audrey - I want to go
and find out why those plants need to
come to another world in order to take
it over I need to find out how long
they've been doing it I want to find out
how their civilization works are their
little plant babies we know that there
are how do they aside from reproducing
just from around are their plant
families or their other things around
that it's an interesting world it's a
world that we have unexplored and it's
something that we can see that truly
doesn't do anything that makes you go oh
well now I look at all of the rest of
this thing that I loved before
differently it is truly its own unique
thing and then when Audrey too comes
down it will be Audrey too and you will
still appreciate what the musical was
without it having really any effect on
you watch it now and you go oh that's
how that happened oh he's named solo cuz
he was alone birth none of those
problems are gonna happen with my Little
Shop of Horrors prequel musical all
right a little Shop of Horrors prequel
coy I once again same same ideas mine
also doesn't mess with mythology mine is
an anthology prequel I love that
anthology shows exist I love it like
American Horror Story you can just jump
in I love
world exists there aren't in my opinion
of anthology films and I would choose
la-la-land to begin shaping an anthology
musical series about Los Angeles I want
to see more about LA I was so excited
when they originally saying true
detective season 2 was about how they
shut down the electric car and was gonna
be about like the corrupt system of LA
and how like that ruined America that
was the thing that was interesting to me
because the mythology of LA is
fascinating there are so many movies
about the New York crime scene and the
Boston departed world and all those
things I want to see more about LA and I
want to do a musical called lala land
Sunset Strip I want a musical set in the
80s on the Sunset Strip seeing the rise
of rock culture I want to set the
whiskey I wanted at the Viper Room I
want at the Roxy I want a movie that is
in the same genre as lala land with
original music but that 80's rock vibe
that shaped so much of American culture
American culture is founded on the
Sunset Strip with a lot of music and I
want to see that movie come to play and
then you've got a third film which you
can keep in that world called la-la-land
valley girl set in the 50s and you can
do a literal 50s movie ala grease
without messing up the mythology you can
have all these characters maybe they're
related maybe they're not maybe it ties
together maybe there's a winking nod to
they walk by a building that's later
been trashed
maybe the jazz club in la-la land is
referenced as being built in my movie in
the 80s you can build an entire
mythology without messing with the prior
established norm and you can have it be
based around music and that's what made
lala land so great is the music was
important and there's no weird jazz like
snooty 2-d subtext thank you Scott
Mann's huh
thank you coy Mike I am going to choose
one of the best movie musicals of all
time and make a prequel out of it the
movie the original is of course Purple
Rain there it is
the immortal Prince and look there are
five albums before Purple Rain okay
there's a lot of music before this
iconic album comes out I am going to
look I do I think there should be five
movies yeah five prequels of course I do
I will choose though one of my favorites
of his albums dirty mind okay he's a
young man he plays the kid in Purple
Rain so let's go even back to when he's
just hitting puberty okay this is gonna
be iMac I'll call it a romp a bit of a
romp sort of a
sex comedy okay for you know for a
specific generation right there's some
of the best first of all music wise a
musical needs to have amazing songs done
I should kind of just win here because
these songs are better than any songs
that are gonna be in these two prequels
okay no offense Menken no offense
whoever that person was that made Lalo
and that's not being dismissive I just
don't know thank you but we're talking
about songs like dirty mine when you
were mine which was covered by somebody
these are all fantastic songs and
they're going to show the kid Prince's
character at age you know whenever kids
hit puberty 12 13 14 and it's gonna be
just about sort of the the you know the
the horrible thoughts you start to get
in adolescence but instead of expressing
them in terrible ways he's gonna join a
band he's gonna express them through
song in a nice safe way folks print
dirty mind prequel to Purple Rain Oh
three delightful different choices fight
it out please okay so you originally
suggested I love Purple Rain Purple Rain
is one of my favorite movies but you
originally suggested that it was going
to be a sexy drop do not want to see a
sexier a thirteen-year-old through songs
subject matter again he doesn't have two
thrusts he's not gonna be wearing the
iconic song picture from the album dirty
minds Purple Rain and if you're going
back into his childhood what that means
is you're going even deeper into when
his dad was the worst he grew up in an
abusive household you cannot you you
can't ignore that if you're going to be
talking about this and so what you
initially pitched was a sexy Rob there
is nothing sexy about an abusive
household well that's true we're gonna
stay away from that house bald he's
gonna be a band practice a little bit
before we're not gonna go obviously that
stuff's gonna be in the background but
this is gonna be him figuring out a
music Prince without princes and like
the purple rains icon is Prince like
even Batman is Prince Prince who on
earth could play pretend on and unknown
known as Prince and I will
do a wide sweep at a large casting call
for a young man who is like prison I
don't wanna see prints I don't want to
see Bowie I don't want to see these
icons be tarnished and and for me like
what's invasion of the body snatchers
without bodies to snatch like if you
like Michael Bay's sequels without the
human relation you're on a planet where
you're not invested in the character so
I like Michael Bay you know the first
Transformers in bumblebee because of the
relationship between so it humanized the
animals who you feel for the other
robots with the Body Snatchers if it's
an origin before you see their backstory
I don't know how invested I'll be in the
in the creek well you can absolutely be
invested in them because in my in my
take on this movie because obviously
this was also about sending our pitch my
idea is much like our own earth they
have ruined the earth they are plant
creatures there are certain things they
need to survive they need co2 and in
this case they have evolved to need
blood because they have destroyed their
own environment how do they get to that
point does anyone help them my is more
of a Rise of the Planet of the Apes
style but with John details and some
Little Richard and so it's about how how
they have gotten to the point where
there will be good plants who argue that
no we do not need to go across the
galaxy and get blood from other people
we need to fix what we have right now
and then there will be bad plants are
like we think to go to these other
planets and we need to suck the literal
lifeblood out of these people and so
what you're watching is you are watching
these two opposing ideologies until
finally unfortunately sadly with a
beautiful Sun in their heart you watch
the good plants either die or get put
away everyone loves look the best
musicals end with sad sad death you know
here you watch you go back and watch
West Side Story sad sad death lesson
learned and that's what's gonna happen
in my movies sad sad death lesson
learned
I've been coming down to earth well why
would you be invested in the creatures
if it's a pretty like what would invest
you in these things that don't
necessarily translate to us like Planet
of the Apes they're very humanoid so
we're there and we kind of add some big
lips short but like you look like any
Instagram model but that's like Dark
Crystal prequel like we don't want a
Dark Crystal prequel then to try and do
that forever like
dude they don't look exactly like us but
we still find it to love them in Lion
King yes they have eyes but they Lyons
dude I don't know if you know this there
was a super dupe lion star looks like a
blue jet line just seems like an epic
they're having an ethical dilemma for
two hours and then people die it's Sun
suppressing on is worse there's no
goodies really haven't captured that yet
like the dirt but good we don't want to
see a plant seeing a version if I
dreamed a dream except being able to
breathe I do a lot of I'm Kelly again
Ferg Ali's dope and I can watch like you
know happy dirt aren't we so tired of LA
writers telling everybody else how dope
LA is yes we're in the time yet we've
done it modern we've done a classic I
think the 80s is not an era we've really
done with the label well no and this
wasn't a musical but we had all of
Entourage if you want to see the Sunset
Strip if you want to see all of the yeah
I want to talk about the Bugsy Siegel
era I want to talk when their founding
these like skeezy clubs I want to talk
about the Mafia underbelly that found in
LA so much of LA is crime and we haven't
touched from that we've already done
that in Chinatown let's just do a
musical Chinatown Wow and the low-end
it's like a very like nice nice feeling
bland like there's no way these things
are gonna totally fit into lala land
it's classic rock tone it's eighties
rock to roll that into five yeah so what
I'm saying is I don't want to see you
know there's that beautiful hopeful
version of everyone dancing about how
much they love being in LA on the thing
I don't want to see a bunch of heroin
addicts doing that on the Sunset Strip
you sad songs
don't want to watch that movie um so for
me it's interesting as it might be to
have another level and see a movie I
don't the anthology I think does not
work I think that most people in most
states are really over all of us in LA
essing are our DS I think that they want
to see movies they're about other things
and as far as the Purple Reign sequel
goes you cannot cannot cannot this goes
to my point about casting
you can't recast prints my dude he's
prints and one less we're gonna make
janelle monae a thirteen-year-old that's
the only way that we can do prints in my
movie you take away all of those factors
where it's it's a story about good
versus evil there are people who are
working very very hard our plants who
are working very very hard their plants
we're trying to work against the other
plants and at the end you do get that
beautiful bit of that sadness and that
melancholy that you see in a Hamilton
that you see in in other movies where
it's like oh man this is super sad
there's a little shop of horrors ended
with Audrey being straight-up killed by
Audrey too and so this completely works
for me and that's why I say a little
shelf course thanks Danielle background
koi for me an anthology series of films
makes it work in anything it doesn't
have to feel like long line for me what
sells it is lala land Sunset Strip is a
genre of film that doesn't exist yet
like when anthology film doesn't exist
in this way an 80s rock is so important
for the music we live now and whether
you like LA or hate it or whether you're
sick about it or not it's so much of
American pop culture that people don't
know about the crime people don't know
that these clubs were founded by
mobsters people don't know about the
music scene and I totally agree the
sadness and the highs and lows of the
80s is so important for the culture we
live in now the highs of cocaine-fueled
ladies gave us most the movies we love
today and the lows of the 90s and the
grunge fell from that we started wearing
those flannels because the low come down
from all the co peed in the 80s that's
an important story to tell I want to see
the calm down from coke eighties I think
that can only be done be done in a
musical and I think that you won't be
able to sell that because of people
being Sigmund unless you tie it's lala
land
now you'd shape it like lala land where
it's an actual oskar film it doesn't
invest
again but that's fair and you shape it
with a very intellectually driven script
so you finally have credibility to the
Sunset Strip so people stop thinking
about his entourage
people stop thinking about it in the
dirt they start seeing the important
heritage of LA because it shapes all of
American culture and then you can tie in
another one that shapes American culture
before that I want to tell the story of
America through music and that's what
musicals can do
thanks coy Mike I think when you're
looking at a prequel you want something
that shares DNA with the original movie
like this is a fine idea to go through
the musical thing in LA or whatever but
I think you want something that connects
it this feels like a totally different
movie this feels like Rock of Ages maybe
a slightly prestige Rock of Ages which
it's not something I necessarily need to
see I'll be honest with you but I maybe
would watch it it just doesn't I if you
really love lala land you're gonna want
to see stuff from Lalla and you wanna
get the vibe or whatever and this is not
gonna give it as far as a little shout
before its prequels I want to see plants
have fun I don't want to see plants
debate big issues okay we have all these
wonderful puppet plants and we're just
gonna see them like have ethical
dilemmas and crisis of conscience I mean
what are we doing here let's see them
grow up and spit out seeds at each other
and have high jinks that's what I want
to see for a plant movie dirty mine
first of all there's a show called pen15
right now we do we need an art that
explores what it's like to be adolescent
what it's like to be super horned up at
a certain age okay we don't have to be
graphic we don't have to be weird about
it and I think that Janelle Monae thing
is really great because I'm pen15
some older comedians play themselves at
that age let's do Janelle Monae let's
have her play a thirteen-year-old and
she sings some of the greatest songs
ever some of the weirdest hornies songs
Prince ever wrote it's called dirty mind
a prequel to Purple Rain were aware of
business here folks let's be honest
that's the one you all want to see the
most all right there it is one
in the facts to check I do have to
mention a lot of people in the chatroom
mentioned it Mike brought it up at the
very end Rock of Ages is a rock musical
that is set on the Sunset Strip in the
year 1987 well it's not prestige but the
bourbon room in that in that musical
amend movie is supposed to be the Viper
Room into a but that's true and there's
a monkey with Tom Cruise I mean what do
you want people also mentioned princes
classic track when you'll remind
memorably covered by Cyndi Lauper my
horse I forget I'm sorry pick you up yes
whoo all right three three good films
man Danielle you had some some great
stuff in there as far as little shot
bars and I love Little Shop of Horrors
if you haven't seen it please say it but
I feel like they deemed you a little bit
as far as like there are people in the
Little Shop of Horrors and just how do
you make those plants watchable and like
get fill them with no personality
I'll sit sexy plants perhaps and it's
hard to yeah so we have home trees about
to get funky okay I came down to lala
land in Purple Rain to me and you know
what it was lala land all the way for
the longest time but I thought Mike had
a great closing argument there and he
leaned into okay yeah it doesn't you
know we can play with the casting there
are shows that go that delve into how
difficult adolescence is and I think coy
they dinged you a little bit with yeah
just totally it's different from the
film doesn't work Rock of Ages was
brought up so yeah I think Mike just got
won me over in that final round so I'm
gonna Mike Loong I'd say
there was one fairly clear winner for me
just about the whole time
I loved the dirty mind album I love
Prince but I had a really hard time
picturing how this movie would work some
unknown kid trying to perform these
Prince Hans I just I don't know I think
I think they kind of dinged him on that
and and then if Danielle had I do it
sounds a lot more like Rock of Ages than
la blaw manages I'm not sure how it sort
of fits into the lala land sort of tone
or style that sounds like such a
different project so yeah in the end I
thought Danielle made a really
compelling case I love the reference to
Rise of the Planet of the Apes that
we're really seeing this sort of totally
different version of the story so yeah
I'm going Danielle all right so we have
Mike Danielle Ryan what do we got on the
pole all right this one was not as close
as the last couple of rounds at the
runaway winner over 60% of the vote was
a little shop of horrors Danielle makes
it when the rage is zero
you know what is happening I suck at
this game not today you don't
any were there any other good
suggestions there by the way there were
a bunch of some good ones some people
wanted a lot of Rocky Horror Picture
Show show teaching middle school musical
I saw that one on Twitter and High
School Musical oh yeah lon I did he did
put his hand up because he does want the
Dark Crystal prequel as well and poop
trash bucket that pop star would be a
good prequel I just wanted to say in a
bucket I was trying to give as many
shoutouts that yeah
style boys the story that's all ready to
go I believe Logan our Facebook guy was
the one he mentioned that first he said
oh that would be great over pop star
prequel zero zero to see who will get
into the spin round to face this force
of nature known as Danielle Radford's
a30 yes it is true that is true story
okay so Mike coy the tiebreaker works
the same as a speed round I will ask the
question shout out your answers then you
get twenty seconds to elaborate in the
order that you answered and then
10-second rebuttals okay y'all ready for
this here we go jeremy renner is
planning to bring back Hawkeye for a new
Disney Plus series but if he chose not
to return what other actor would you
want to see take on Clint Barton Hawkeye
another actor would like to play Hawkeye
Jeremy Renner didn't return Nick
Offerman
Nick Offerman Armie Hammer
Armie Hammer okay we heard Mike first
Nick Offerman 20 seconds begin when you
speak alright Nick first of all get on
HGH start working out baby because
you're gonna do this we're gonna base
this on Matt fractions awesome run of
Hawkeye he's in an apartment building
he's just dealing with like stuff people
there's goons he's got a dog this is
just every man Hawkeye this is what Nick
Offerman is gonna excel at obviously
visually like we can work on his body
but he is somebody who you root for who
you want to believe in who somebody who
you believe would care about it armie
hammer is also playing everyman Hawkeye
but it's gonna be with Kate Bishop he's
gonna be training camp Bishop we finally
need Kate Bishop in the end see you she
is the hawk I had set on West Coast
based off the all-new Hawkeye he is the
everyman looking a Man From UNCLE look
at his other movies look at him in that
movie that some of these shall hate
every man Hawkeye training a young new
Hawkeye that would actually be watching
an army hammer has that place you just
assume is superior and be middle
backstory minimal screen
would actually have time to introduce
Kate vigil armie hammer too hot to be
Hawkeye Hawkeye is in every man he's a
dude you know him a nickel off Herman is
a dude all the way it's gonna do what
Chris Pratt the same fake transformation
will happen or he and I will be a
leading man that can do people think
about Hawkeye is that he looks like a
superhero but he acts like an everyman
our me hammer is the exact same thing
it's perfect casting its you see guy oh
that's a superhero but he acts like an
everyman and he's already introduced
with Kate Bishop which is the better
story to tell all along foreign
television show us that was a tough one
I think especially if we're considering
that were it's saying it's the MCU
Hawkeye that was taking over that role
actually I really liked the way Mike
approached it with that we know that
this Hawkeye is one that does just want
to kind of be around the he just wants
to go back to his ranch with his family
that's kind of been his motivation he's
like I got to get out and do this again
and I think the progressive that Nick
Offerman could slide and that really
well I thought Mike did a good job
saying that so I'd take him to the speed
round yeah I thought we had so it's one
for Mike I thought we had two great
opening rounds and yeah I thought Mike
parried all of quois attacks and yeah by
a hair I got a go Mike with the eye when
you said Nick Offerman I was like aha
but then like HGH get them in check fab
you know I got me on many points so yeah
Mike you're going to the speed round
collation man Raziel all right Carson
Hawkeye we don't get a there's no point
for that so Danielle enters the speed
round at game point up three Oh Mike I
talked about at the top of the show
it's if you want this you're gonna have
to make the furious comeback boy well
fought all the way through thank you
brother all right
here is question Helen and the speed
round works the same as the tiebreaker
Justin I'll ask the question answer 20
seconds and then 10 seconds of models
question one this Sunday kicks off the
final season of Game of Thrones which G
ot character would inspire the best
spin-off film series
John snow grey worm we got John snow
we got grey worm we heard John snow
first Mike 20 seconds begin when you
speak John snow is such a rich character
okay he's misunderstood he's a little
bit of a wiener I think that this is a
character that once you finally explore
he goes off on his own you see what
happened you see what he grew up you see
the parts that are in between that are
missing from the others you're gonna
have a lot to explore the actor is like
a great I forget his name he's a very
moody guy it's gonna be very it's like
very much like a whenever you're ready
so with grammar and what you have is
something new that you haven't seen
before but you have it with the grey
worm where it is a warrior who was
learning how to put down his sword his
fight has ended he has fought for other
people for his entire life and now he
has to learn how to actually live a life
and how to love and it will still be
adventurous he will still walk the earth
like Cain and he will still fight but
this time he will fight for himself
instead of fighting for a queen and a
fine first slave master and for the
funny to other people
there's funny movies where a person puts
down the sword dirty hair like dirty
hair I think is the movie I'm leaning
over now maybe it's not John Stone
that's gonna be something different
that's gonna be more like a petulant
kind of teen drama we're gonna see a
different tone I think that we've
already seen enough of John Snow
this was essentially John so series I
feel like we've already gotten to see
everything we're gonna see what Jon Snow
wears with grey worm there are a lot of
things you can also cover you could also
cover his earlier life and have him do
flashbacks all right whoo good stuff you
guys lon where you at on this pretty
very good first rounds very very
carefully balanced Kit Harington yeah
Jon Snow actor the second the second
half Danielle really pulled away I think
I got a much more sort of clear idea of
what the gray worms show could be and I
sort of agree like we've seen a lot of
judge snow be interesting to blow up
sort of a minor character I'm going with
Danielle all right Lon's going with
Danielle and for many of the same
reasons I also got to go with Danielle
Danielle you just want movie fights
[Applause]
I've never seen the show Game of Thrones
pilot Wow Michael thank you for thank
you for your not a game of Thrones watch
your eyes no I don't like investing in
characters that I like I know they're
gonna die why would I be like I love him
oh no I'll get to it maybe I just sure
I'm not against watching fascinating but
you know it's also fascinating
Danielle pitched a shutout today for
love Danielle go ahead give some
shoutouts celebrate if you want to pop
up with a bottle of champagne III don't
this is not welcome to my house I don't
have a champagne bottle to pop I'm no
flo rida but i yeah this is crazy so
yeah we you know for movie fight or not
for movie fights that that's the show
for honest trailers we just put out the
honest trailer for moral engines y'all
go watch that I've been doing a lot of
the others trailers and these have been
great and we've been doing one of the
commentaries which has been really fun
for me so the best way you can support
me is to commute to watch all the stuff
that I do so if people will give me the
money I guess I can keep doing this
stuff and paying rent and then that's
how we get enough new dresses you guys
new dresses new dresses this is an old
dress that I haven't worn before because
it doesn't go weird thing on camera but
it's also like laundry day well it
looked looks great to me and I saw there
was an awesome tweet from one of the
actors in immortal engines the the new
honest trailer which she was saying like
she was so thrilled that she got honest
trailer eyes so that Sun heard from a
few people who were in it including one
who was like how come I didn't make the
list of the most attractive people
you're right you are all incredibly you
just don't know we didn't have time to
show the pretty people in the
post-apocalyptic sorry to everybody in
young Hollywood
awesome work honest trailers and today
on movie fights Mike Carlson always
hilarious and thank you for making at
what am I truly one of my all-time faves
South Park bigger Longer on fire tell us
about your podcast and any other stuff
sure I'm fat Carlson on Twitter uh
podcast called podcast the ride it's
about rides and theme parks and then
also on our patreon which is like extra
bonus episodes we get into stuff like
McGruff music career we will we'll be
doing a turn Ninja Turtles coming out of
their shells episode soon so we get into
like just more weird nostalgia stuff so
if you like that kind of good stuff
podcast the ride all the places you can
find podcasts heck yeah thank you Mike
and quick plug Mike Carlson and my good
Mike coy John drew they're both gonna be
at tournament 420 yeah
420 midnight if you're in LA come to
tournament of nerds at the UCB to see
these guys do some fun nerdy stuff and
coy always great to have you um go ahead
and not plug anything my first no point
game I gotta say that was incredible I
was a hell of a fight and I did I do
Collider heroes every week we just
started comic-book shopping back up and
this Tuesday is Hellboy himself David
Harbor and I went comic book shopping so
I was very excited to see this theme has
been David Harbor when comic shopping it
was so much for that guy's incredible he
loves Hellboy that was the best
commercial I could've gotten was him
just being like uh he gets it and I also
been doing junkets for Nerdist I am
doing some stuff with Skybound coming up
and then Shazam I did twelve pieces of
press all over the internet for its of
Road magazine coming out sat down with
Jack and Zach sat down with Jack sat
down with Asher do it it's you look
first his name in my name and I had so
much fun with that movie go see Shazam
then see how boy and then let me know
your thought so cool koi thank you for
being here and that sounds like a lot of
awesome stuff
Lana Harris thanks for holding down in
the fact zone always you know just
hanging with Jack and Zach you know me
cash hangs just hanging Wanda what's
your Twitter handle and all that good
stuff finance we're at L o and s and if
unlike these guys you have seen Game of
Thrones heck yes
lon I thank you sir and Ryan O'Toole
thank you for holding it down in social
media chair thank you please go ahead
and tell us a thing a try no true on
Twitter and I just wanted at least give
a shout out to at sleeping shrimp on
Twitter use the hashtag movie fights
live he did Photoshop a corgi on an owl
for Danielle she's I've been waiting I
have the phone with save I will be
showing it to her once the show I think
after a sweet boys really deserved it
true I want to thank everybody for
watching if you're worried about
Percival don't worry I just got a text
that the police broke my window if you
are in LA tomorrow night Friday
oh is it Friday the 12th I was gonna
that knows on Friday 13th Friday the
12th at 10:30 p.m. at the PAC Theatre
I'm hosting a talk show gonna be a lot
of fun on 4/20 tournament of nerds at
the UCB theater in Los Angeles and yeah
follow me on instagram twitter at how
rudnick there's a lot of dumb stuff
going on there hoot hoot thanks again
for watching bye bye thanks Billy busy
you